business has been struggling for a  number of years changing tastes a lot of  the designs and fabrics enos a bit  chintzy in this day and age it's trading  from something like a hundred and fifty  shops across the country it will likely  result in around 2,700 people losing  their jobs Sky News reported at the  weekend that it was in potential talks  with the private equity company Hill Co  about a possible rescue deal that was  after it failed to obtain credit from  other lenders Wells Fargo the big US  bank I think is on the hook for about 20  million pounds here but I mean this is a  business to be frank that's been  struggling for an awful long time as I  say partly a function of changing tastes  changing consumer habits as well trading  from too many outlets and really the  writing had been on the wall for this  business for a very long time Jane